i
[Música]
llegó a su orilla la mayoría de las
siendo una personas que habían sido
evacuadas durante este fin de semana
desde la planta siderúrgica de as hostal
en la ciudad asediada de mariupol otros
200 civiles permanecen en la acería
atacada hoy por las fuerzas del kremlin
la corte suprema de justicia de eeuu
confirmó la autenticidad del borrador
filtrado que sugiere que el máximo
tribunal podría anular la interrupción
legal del embarazo y ordenó una
investigación sobre la filtración el
presidente joe biden dijo que responderá
si se anula roe versus wait tenemos
reportes desde washington
hoy en el día internacional de la
libertad de prensa naciones unidas y
otras organizaciones exigieron detener
los asesinatos y maltratos a periodistas
en escenarios como la guerra en ucrania
reporteros sin fronteras alertó sobre la
polarización en los medios el caos
informativo y la desinformación
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz comenzamos este
informativo con la guerra en ucrania
porque naciones unidas confirmó que más
de 100 civiles fueron evacuados con
éxito de la planta de azov tales
mariupol y la cruz roja informó que la
mayoría ya está en sap orilla donde
reciben atención prioritaria se estima
que todavía hay unos 200 ciudadanos en
la acería y 100.000 habitantes atrapados
en el casco urbano del puerto tomado por
los rusos de otro lado las tropas del
kremlin atacaron este martes a shocks
tal rusia argumenta que ucrania
aprovechó el alto el fuego del fin de
semana para reposicionarse en la ciudad
ahora hay temor por la suerte de los
militares que se refugian en el lugar
entre tanto rusia atacó un aeródromo
militar cerca de la ciudad de odessa en
el suroeste de ucrania destruyendo
drones misiles y municiones
suministradas a ucrania por eeuu y sus
aliados europeos los misiles y la
artillería rusos también alcanzaron
varios objetivos militares los ataques
también se registraron en la ciudad de
donges donde murieron al menos nueve
personas y en jarque cayó un misil en el
centro de la ciudad
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski habló al parlamento de albania
y no solo agradeció el apoyo a su país y
las sanciones impuestas al gobierno ruso
sino que pidió que se aplique más
medidas económicas contra el kremlin el
mandatario sugirió que la unión europea
debería imponer un embargo a la
importación de petróleo ruso un tema que
ha causado división dentro del bloque ya
que países como hungría y eslovaquia
dependen altamente de los hidrocarburos
rusos
ahora cuando la unión europea' discuta
el sexto paquete de sanciones contra
rusia juntos debemos insistir en aplicar
un embargo petrolero como parte de eso
así como un bloqueo serio de cualquier
esquema que rusia use para engañar al
mundo libre e ignorar las sanciones los
bancos rusos deben ser completamente
expulsados del sistema financiero
internacional
y también en el plano diplomático el
primer ministro británico gordon soon se
convirtió en el primer líder occidental
en dirigirse al parlamento ucraniano
desde que comenzó la invasión rusa a
través de una videoconferencia el
mandatario anunció otros 300 millones de
libras esterlinas en ayuda militar
además invocó las palabras del fallecido
líder británico winston churchill en
tiempos de la segunda guerra mundial
cuando reinó unido- enfrentaba la
amenaza de ser invadido y derrotado por
la alemania nazi y elogió la resistencia
de los ucranianos a los ataques rusos
así expresó su confianza en que ucrania
ganaría la guerra
weiss
y aunque sus soldados siempre fueron
superados en número de 3 a 1 lucharon
con el valor y la energía de los leones
y han vencido desde kiev han hecho
estallar el mito de que putin es
invencible y han escrito uno de los
capítulos más gloriosos de la historia
militar y de la vida de su país en el
tri street and life
odio contra la llamada fuerza
irresistible de la máquina de guerra de
putin se ha estrellado contra el objeto
inamovible del patriotismo ucraniano y
el amor a la patria
en love
este es el mejor momento en ucrania que
será recordado y contado para las
generaciones venideras
dos miembros de trànsit
el presidente francés emmanuel macro ni
su homólogo ruso vladimir putin
sostuvieron una nueva conversación
telefónica la primera desde el pasado 29
de marzo en ella el mandatario galo le
dijo a putin que un cese el fuego era
necesario en ucrania y le pidió que
permitiera la continuación de las
evacuaciones de los civiles refugiados
en las hostal desde parís nuestra
periodista erika olavarría con los
detalles
las primeras informaciones sobre esta
larga llamada telefónica de dos horas
entre putin y macros llegaron desde
moscú fue el kremlin que informó que el
presidente ruso pidió a su homólogo
francés que si occidente quiere detener
las atrocidades en ucrania deje de
enviar armas a ese país y también
aconseje de manera apropiada a las
autoridades quien -según a moscú ellos
siguen abiertos al diálogo sin embargo
el presidente silencio y sus gobiernos
no están preparados para llevar
seriamente las compensaciones de paz
putin criticó también a la unión europea
porque no condena los crímenes de guerra
dijo él ni los bombardeos masivos que
realiza ucrania en el este del país
hablaron también de la evacuación de
civiles desde la planta de s'hostal en
mariupol gracias a la mediación de
naciones unidas' putin dijo que los
civiles son retenidos allí por
nacionalistas ucranianos el presidente
macrón en cambio pidió hablar de la
seguridad alimentaria puesta en riesgo
debido a este conflicto putin dijo que
es la responsabilidad de las sanciones
de occidente en contra de su país
recordemos que esta es la primera
conversación telefónica entre ambos
líderes desde el pasado 29 de marzo eso
es un poco antes de que se conociera la
masa de busca en la periferia de kiev
esas imágenes que dieron la vuelta al
mundo de civiles muertos en las calles
que el presidente macro calificó de
insoportables en ese momento macrón
pidió a las autoridades rusas hacerse
cargo de estos crímenes por cierto moscú
siempre ha negado ser el responsable de
esta masacre
y la izquierda francesa concreta
alianzas de cara a las elecciones
legislativas del mes de junio en torno a
la figura del ex candidato presidencial
jean luc mélenchon hace poco se confirmó
que el partido comunista acordó sumarse
al programa conjunto conformado por la
formación de mi elección la francia en
su misa a la que este lunes se unieron
los ecologistas los socialistas podrían
ser los próximos en sumarse sin embargo
las conversaciones continúan y se les
dio un plazo hasta esta noche para tomar
una decisión la izquierda busca hacerse
con una mayoría en el parlamento para
hacer contrapeso al gobierno de manuel
macro
pasamos a eeuu la corte suprema de
justicia confirmó la autenticidad del
borrador filtrado y que sugiere que el
máximo tribunal podría anular el fallo
que garantiza el derecho a la
interrupción legal del embarazo en vigor
desde 1973 según un documento del
presidente del supremo habrá una
investigación para determinar cómo se
filtró el texto cientos de personas a
favor del aborto empezaron a congregarse
desde anoche a las afueras de la ciudad
de la corte suprema de justicia en
washington para expresar su rechazo se
espera que los jueces emitan su fallo a
principios de julio el presidente joe
biden calificó el borrador como radical
y mencionó que no sabe si este proyecto
es genuino o definitivo pero que su
administración está lista para
garantizar este derecho puesto en primer
lugar acabo de recibir una llamada
diciendo que se ha anunciado que es un
borrador real pero aún no representa a
quien votará por él espero que no haya
suficientes votos
la idea
la idea que me preocupa mucho es que
después de 50 años vamos a decidir que
una mujer no tiene derecho a elegir
según los límites de la decisión de la
corte suprema-
y para ampliar esta noticia saludamos en
washington a nuestro corresponsal
cristóbal vázquez cristóbal muy buenos
días háblenos por favor de la filtración
en qué momento ocurrió cómo se dio
cuando se escribió y qué más dice este
borrador
pues este borrador es de el 10 de
febrero por eso varios analistas y
varias reacciones a cargo sin ton dicen
que es preliminar que no es el documento
final y que también implicaría que los
jueces que en este momento apoyan ese
borrador podrían cambiar de opinión es
entonces un borrador del 10 de febrero
que ha generado mucha polémica porque es
la primera vez en la historia reciente
que se filtra una decisión preliminar de
los magistrados de la corte suprema de
justicia antes de que se emita
precisamente este fallo que se daría en
cuestión de dos meses los que apoyen
esta decisión son cinco de los nueve
magistrados el que escribió este
documento de 98 páginas que fue filtrado
anoche publicado por el medio político
muy activo y muy presente en la capital
y sobre todo en la corte suprema de
justicia pues son los siguientes estos
magistrados son emmy con berti que fue
denominada por el expresidente donald
trump pero también está cavallotto el
curso y pues es samuel a nito además de
clarín tomas el juez john roberts es el
que es de tendencia conservadora todavía
no se conoce cuál sería entonces su
posición una vez se tome la decisión
final sobre este documento que es de
insistir hay que resaltar es un
documento pues que es un borrador
todavía no está finalizado completamente
sin embargo argumenta que pues en
ninguna parte de la constitución y no en
la enmienda número 14 está el tema del
aborto en el este está carta
constitucional de eeuu cristóbal el juez
john roberts precisamente anunció una
investigación también habló al
presidente yo bailén que otras
reacciones se conocen frente a ésta este
borrador
la corte suprema de justicia donde
estamos en este momento está justo al
frente del capitolio varios senadores
varios congresistas han caminado aquí
donde están las protestas desde anoche a
expresarse estuvo acá
la senadora conclusiones ella de
tendencia liberal dijo que pues era una
decisión eliminar bastante cuestionable
por parte de los jueces conservadores
invito a los estadounidenses a votar a
hacer presencia sobre todo en el voto de
noviembre en las legislativas para que
se haga contrapeso desde el congreso a
la corte suprema de justicia que
recordemos tiene una mayoría
conservadora porque seis de los nueve
jueces de la corte suprema pues son de
tendencia conservadora también shocks yo
me dijo que iba a impulsar una votación
en el senado para para proteger el
aborto y también lisa murkowski que es
republicana y senadora también bastante
influyente porque es una de las
senadoras que
en el péndulo que a pesar de ser
republicana tiende a votar por
iniciativas liberales dijo también que
este borrador y esta decisión preliminar
por parte de los magistrados de la corte
suprema de justicia ninawa la confianza
del punto estadounidense en la
institución judicial y bien cristóbal
gracias por este reporte nosotros
estaremos atentos a lo que sucede con
esta noticia y hoy es el día mundial de
la libertad de prensa naciones unidas
dice que esta fecha debe servir de
recordatorio a los gobiernos sobre la
necesidad de respetarla por su parte la
ong reporteros sin fronteras publicó su
clasificación anual e incluyó en su
lista roja un número récord de 26 países
en reconocimiento a su valentía frente a
la represión la unesco ha concedido este
año el premio mundial de la libertad de
prensa a la principal organización de
periodistas independientes de belarús
a veces se dice que ya no hay periodismo
en belarús lo que no es cierto
la gente trabaja allí redacciones
enteras trabajan a pesar de las graves
amenazas y la enorme presión a la que se
enfrentan
el día mundial de la libertad de prensa
es también un sombrío recordatorio de lo
peligroso que es para los periodistas
hacer su trabajo no solo en las zonas de
guerra sino en las sociedades
democráticas los reporteros se han
convertido en objetivos en la guerra de
ucrania en mexico ocho periodistas han
sido asesinados en lo que va del año
y 884 perdieron la vida solo por hacer
su trabajo entre 2012 y 2021 en casi
nueve de cada diez casos estos
asesinatos no se resuelven y siguen
impunes
en
reporteros sin fronteras ha clasificado
como muy mala la situación de la
libertad de prensa en un número récord
de 26 países
mientras que las democracias
escandinavos ocupan la mejor posición
iran eritrea y corea del norte son los
tres peores hong kong cayó en picada en
la clasificación internacional ya que
beijing intensificó la represión de las
voces críticas rusia también está en la
lista roja al intentar amordazar a los
medios de comunicación con una nueva ley
que podría encarcelar a cualquiera por
difundir lo que el kremlin considera
información falsa pero ucrania también
ha bajado en la tabla esto debido a las
intensas campañas de propaganda en este
país que amenazan la libertad de prensa
y hoy se cumplen 15 años de la
desaparición de madeleine mccann la niña
británica que fue vista por última vez
la noche del 3 de mayo de 2007 cuando
solo tenía 3 años de edad durante unas
vacaciones en praia da luz con su
familia la menor se encontraba durmiendo
en su habitación en un centro turístico
en el sur de portugal mientras sus
padres cenaban con amigos a pocos metros
de distancia a través de un comunicado
kate y gerry mccann se refirieron a este
episodio como un crimen horrible y hoy
todavía mantienen la esperanza de poder
volver a ver a su hija
musulmanes de todo el mundo continúan
celebrando el eid al-fitr la fecha que
marca el fin del mes sagrado del ramadán
en india miles de devotos se reunieron
desde tempranas horas de la mañana en
varias ciudades del país para ofrecer
sus oraciones las multitudinarias
reuniones se dan dos años después de
estrictas restricciones destinadas a
frenar el avance del cob y 19 en uno de
los países más golpeados por el virus
con estas imágenes despedimos este
informativo en france 24 gracias por
acompañarnos continúan con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]